برايك ما الذي جعل هرزي هاليفي يصف القتال
في غزه بانه معقد
للغايه لانه بالفعل يعني واجهوا واجهوا
مقاتلين لم يعتادوا على مثل هذه البساله
هذه الشجاعه هذا التطور النوعي في اداء
هؤلاء المقاتلين هذه اليقضه الجاهزيه
العاليه وهو ايضا تحدث عن جاهزيتهم وتحدث
بطريقه غير مباشره عن عن كفاءتهم وخاصه
انه المقاوم الفلسطيني يبرع الان على ارضه
وملعبه وفي ويؤدي مهارات ميدانيه وقتاليه
اعتقد انها اذهلت الجيش الاسرائيلي واذهلت
قياده الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا يعود مرده
الى ان المقاومين الفلسطينيين
اولا يعرفون طبيعه العدو يعرفون كل
تكتيكات العدو كل سيناريوهات العدو ما قام
به العدو في اعتداءاته السابقه وما قام
فيه منذ شهرين في اعتداءاته الحاليه
المقاومين الفلسطينيين هم انفسهم واجهوا
انواع مت متعدده من الجنود يعني هناك هناك
وحدات عسكريه تبدلت ولكن المقاوم
الفلسطيني لم يتبدل المقاوم الفلسطيني
قاتل الدفعات الاولى وقاتل الدفعات التي
تلتها وقاتل الدفعات الحاليه بمعنى انه مع
كل دفعه ويتعلم دروس ويراكم خبرات جديده
في حين ان في حين ان الجندي الاسرائيلي
الذي لا يعرف كيف يقاتل هل هو سيقاتل فوق
الارض ام سيقاتل تحت الارض سيقاتل انفاق
غير معلومه لا لا يوجد لديه معلومات امنيه
واستخبارات يفقد اسناده القريب والبعيد
سواء كان من الجو او من المدفعيه البريه
والبحريه وعدم قدرته على التكيف مع الواقع
الجديد الذي وضع فيه اضافه الى ما يطلق من
فوق راس
من رصاص ومن صواريخ ومن قذائف هاون هذه
كلها تؤثر على كفاءته القتاليه وروحه
المعنويه وقد تابعنا بعض المشاهد قبل قليل
لا سما تلك المتعلقه بعمليه استدراج قوات
الاحتلال الى فتحه احد الانفاق اود ان
اسالك هنا عن هذا الاثر الذي اي تحدثه
عمليات الاستدراج ومقتل الجنود
الاسرائيليين امام فتحات النفق بهذا الشكل
علما ان الانفاق هي الهدف الرئيسي لهم اي
بعد
التوغل يعني هذا ان دل على شيء يدل على ان
الجنود الاسرائيليين حتى الان غير قادرين
على التكيف مع هذا الواقع الجديد الذي وضع
يفيه وهذا يعود طبعا لبساله وقدره
المقاومه الفلسطينيه على خوض هذه المعركه
هي اولا قبل قبل الكفاءه وقبل الشجاعه
وقبل الاستبسال هي معركه عقول وادم ومعركه
تخطيط يعني الجندي الاسرائيلي الذي دخل
الى هذا النفق بهذه الطريقه وشاهدنا كيف
تصرف معه المقاومين الفلسطينيين انا
بتقديري يعني هي ل ليست ادخلت الرعب في
قلبه وا ايضا في عقله وفي قدرته على
التصرف يعني افقدته القدره على التصرف
حقيقه هو اعجاز عسكري و يعني من ناحيه
عسكريه لا يوجد اي شائب على هذه الخطه
وهذه تعتمد على قدره على توقعات بمعنى
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وضعوا سيناريوهات
متعدده لكيفيه تصرف الجنود الاسرائيليين
ووضعوا حلول لكل سيناريو وانا اعتقد انه
ما تم تنفيذه هو احدى السيناريوهات التي
وضعت من قبل المقاومين الفلسطينيين
والدليل على ذلك التصوير يعني التصوير هذا
ان دل على شيء يدل على ان الخطه محكمه وان
قدرتهم على توقعات ما ماذا سيقوم به العدو
من تصرف ومن اجراءات كانت في محلها وهو ما
اربك العدو الاسرائيلي وجعله في حيره من
امره طيب في موضوع محاولات الوصول الى
المحتجزين يقول الناطق العسكري او يتحدث
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي عن عمليات
لتحرير هؤلاء المحتجزين بعضها نفذ وبعضها
الغي لكن كما هو معروف ما تم تنفيذه
انتهى بمقتل المحتجزين
فبالتالي عن ماذا يعبر هذا
الامر اولا اسمح لي اخي ان
اقول ولا اظلم هذا الناطق العسكري حين
اقول انه جاهل جاهل في العلم العسكري
حينما يكون هناك عمليات قد تم تنفيذها على
ارض الواقع فلا داعي ان يخفيها عن الجمهور
الذي يستمع اليه هو دائما يخفي معلومات في
طور في طور تنفيذ وليس نفذت هو تحدث عن
عمليات نفذت وقال لا اريد ان افصل بمعنى
طيب ما هي شا يعني انت عن مين بتخبي بتخبي
عن عدوك ما هو عدوك شافها على الارض وعدوك
قابلها وتصرف على اساسها فبالتالي هذا ان
دل على شيء يدل على جهله وهذا الجهل ايضا
ينطبق على كل احاديثه في المؤتمرات
الصحفيه التي يتلوها على المستمعين هولا
هو لا يعكس الامر الواقع الحقيقي الامر
الواقع الحقيقي مختلف تماما هناك بساله
هناك قدرات لمقاومه الفلسطينيه هناك خطط
محكمه من قبل المقاومين الفلسطينيين افشلت
افشلت الخطط الاسرائيليه صحيح انه حاول
الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من مره تحرير اسرى
ولكن قتلوا قتلوا الاسرى وقتل من جاء من
جاء ليحررهم وهذا ما ما يعني عهدناه قبل
تقريبا شهر حينما جاءت وحده خاصه الى
خانيونس لتحرر اسير وقتل الاسير وقتلت
الوحده الخاصه التي جاءت لتحرر وهذا يعني
اعلن يعني لا لا سر فيه اضافه الى ان هناك
ايضا محاولات اكثر من مره حاول الجيش
الاسرائيلي ولكنه فشل فشل لانه لا يملك
معلومات حقيقيه امنيه او استخباريه كل ما
ملكه هو معلومات استدرج من خلالها من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه شكرا لك اللواء واصف
عريقات الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه حدثتنا
من رام الله